bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux alors ce paléo news le registre
un petit peu en avance parce qu'en
réalité à l'heure où vous voyez cette
vidéo je suis certainement encore sur le
terrain en train de faire des fouilles
dans le karoo donc j'ai enregistré ce
paléo news en avance afin que vous
puissiez le voir pendant que je ne suis
pas là afin d'occuper la chaîne
d'alimenter la chaîne pendant que je
suis pas là donc il est possible qu'ils
aient des choses qui soient sortis entre
deux et que je ne traite pas dans ce
palais aux news mais si c'est le cas ne
vous inquiétez pas je les traiterait
dans le prochain palier aux news ne vous
inquiétez pas là l'actualité a déjà été
suffisamment chargées pour que pour
justifier l'existence de ce premier
paléo news ne vous en faites pas il ya
plein de choses à raconter notamment ces
dernières semaines on a eu le droit
notamment à stan le t-rex stan qui avait
été vendu pour la somme exorbitante de
quasiment 30 2 millions de dollars en
2020 aux enchères ils avaient été vendus
et une vente qui avait suscité
l'indignation
parce que ben parce que le vendeur était
anonyme donc le squelette avait
littéralement disparu on savait pas
qu'il avait acheté on savait pas où il
était parti on savait pas si le
squelette ce serait de nouveau
accessible bref on ne savait rien de ce
qui était arrivé à stan ils étaient pour
ainsi dire disparu et donc on a enfin on
a ce journaliste michael greis co2
national geographic a retrouvé la trace
de stan à abou dhabi donc ce n'est pas
une énorme surprise puisque je veux dire
pour acheter pour pouvoir claqué 32
millions de dollars dans un truc aussi
futile car qu'un squelette de t-rex
sachant que les sachant que les moulages
coûte beaucoup moins cher et sont tout
aussi
tout aussi intéressant je veux dire pour
claquer une somme authie aussi énorme il
fallait évidemment que ça vienne des
émirats du mois on se doutait bien ça
devait venir de quelque part par là donc
bingo ça vient des émirats arabes unis
mais alors la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'ils vont s'en servir pour faire un
musée donc le voilà le muséum d'histoire
naturelle d'abou dhabi a annoncé par le
département de la culture et du tourisme
d'abou dhabi a déclaré officiellement
que c'était eux qui avaient acheté span
on pourra toujours se réjouir que le
squelette de stan fini dans une
collection publique donc un but que
c'est un muséum d'histoire naturelle il
va finir en collections publiques il
n'empêche que la vente de stan reste
reste quand même enfin imposer un
précédent et reste un problème parce que
stan je le rappelle a été collectée par
des paléontologues privé une compagnie
privée qui est spécialisé dans le
pillage
donc ça ça reste un problème puisque
cette compagnie s'est fait littéralement
des testicules en or massif lors de
cette vente 32 millions de dollars quand
même c'est pas rien donc
sahamies déjà ça à financer
littéralement le pillage de plus de
sites un d'une puisque cette compagnie
évidemment faisant un profit va
continuer ses activités donc d'une sa
finance le pillage de sites et de 2 bat
chaque nouvelle vente de t-rex aux
jambes aux enchères
est un nouveau record donc le problème
c'est que les musées ils n'ont pas ces
moyens là donc la plupart des musées du
monde sont pas capables de s'offrir ce
genre de choses voilà il n'y a guère
qu'en chine et aux émirats qu'on va
qu'on va avoir des gens qui auront une
chance de débloquer un budget aussi
colossal et de fait c'est pas notamment
palais musée des états unis qui pourront
profiter de ces fossiles qui viennent
des états unis justement par exemple
donc bon non pas qu'ils manquent de
t-rex mais ça veut dire qu'en gros dans
le futur on peut s'attendre à ce que de
moins en moins les musées est de moins
en moins la chance de pouvoir acheter
des fossiles aux collectionneurs et du
coup il est de moins en moins la chance
de ba2 d'empêcher ces fossiles de finir
dans des collections privées parce que
là pour le coup on a eu du bol avec stan
entre guillemets stan va finir dans une
institution publique on a eu du bol mais
voilà ça a ouvert sa a ouvert la porte
ça a mis en place un précédent qu'est ce
qui va arriver par la suite avec les
futurs fossiles de t-rex qu'on va
découvrir un nul ne le sait et il est
fort probable que les musées n'est pas
vraiment leur mot à dire c'est ce que
rappelle donc intelligemment cet article
de national geographic donc ce qui est
dit ici il est fort probable que les
musées ne puisse plus participer à la
course à la au sauvetage de ces fossiles
que le prix exorbitant de ces fossiles
augmente le pillage parce qu'évidemment
la perspective de pouvoir se faire 32
millions de bulles et c'est pas une
opportunité que que qui que ce soit dans
le monde a les moyens de laisser passer
j'ai envie de dire et vous inquiétez pas
que ici en afrique du sud c'est pas
tombée dans l'oreille d'un sourd il ya
les gens ils ont entendu la nouvelle que
ah ouais on vend des fossiles de
dinosaures à 32 millions et on a plein
de fossiles de dinosaures chez nous
[Musique]
on va aller et puis il ya aussi le fait
que aux états unis là c'est un problème
c'est pas un problème qu aux états unis
d'ailleurs mais en gros les
propriétaires terriens ne vont plus
laisser l'accès qu'aux gens qui ont les
moyens de vendre les fossiles à max de
pépettes c'est à dire que les musées on
n'en veut pas à des musées le musée
pourquoi vous voulez laisser pourquoi
vous voulez laisser un chercheur venir
sur votre terrain ramasser un fossile
gratos alors qu'à côté de ça le black
hills institute donc ces compagnies
privées une de ces grandes compagnies
privées que qui se spécialise dans la
collecte et la revente de fossiles si
vous laissez le black et les instituts
de venir vous pouvez espérer à un beau
petit dividende un beau petit profit en
les laissant revenir plus tôt que les
musées voilà tout ça c'est des problèmes
qui ont été créés par la vente de stan
donc oui stan a été sauvé
mais
comment dire le mal est fait voilà c'est
déjà trop tard en fait le mal est fait
on reste dans les t-rex avec la fameuse
étude qui avait annoncé qu'il met est
qu'il n'y a pas qu'une seule espèce
tyrannosaurus rex mais qu'il y ait en
fait trois espèces de tyrannosaurus
tyrannosaurus regina tyrannosaurus
imperator et tyrannosaurus rex alors
j'ai déjà fait une vidéo là dessus je
vous mets le lien dans la description
j'en ai déjà parlé en détail donc je
vais pas m'étaler sur 7 sur cette étude
plus que ça je vais peut-être juste
répondre à quelques questions et
rappeler rapidement ce que c'était que
ce que c'était que le contexte de cette
étude mais en gros le contexte de cette
étude c'est on a on sait depuis au moins
les années 90 qu'il y à deux morts chez
t-rex inquiets robuste l'autre qui est
gracile donc un avec des eaux épais et
l'autre avec des au plus tôt fin la
question c'est est est ce que le mot hrw
robuste et le mort grâce il serait pas
deux espèces différentes et donc cette
étude répond à cette question en se
disant est ce qu'il y aurait pas deux
espèces différentes et ben ils vous
répondent si il y en a trois
et c'est le problème principal que j'ai
avec cette étude est que j'explique dans
l'autre vidéo
on part avec deux morts fait on finit
avec trois espèces c'est
incompréhensible c'est un article qui
globalement alors quand on voit ici il a
été soumis en le 12 mai 2021 il a été
acceptée le 28 janvier 2022 ce qui veut
dire qu'il a passé quasiment neuf mois
dans les tuyaux
certainement à faire du ping pong en
fait entre les auteurs et les reviewer
les reviewer ce sont des autres quand on
parle de revue par les pairs les
reviewer ce sont des pères en question
qui sont des spécialistes eux mêmes et
juge la teneur scientifique en fait de
l'article avant qu'ils soient publiés
donc évalue la teneur scientifique de
l'article donc ça neuf mois dans les
tuyaux ça veut dire qu'il ya
probablement eu pas mal de ping pong en
fait entre les deux entre les reviewer
et les
les auteurs et savent eux aussi pour ça
doit aussi vouloir dire que l'article en
fait à ça doit expliquer en gros le le
côté un peu frankenstein de l'article en
fait cet article il a une structure un
peu bizarre vous regardez la première
figure par exemple ses joueurs c'est le
symptôme typique
du côté frankenstein de cet article vous
regardez la figure une et regarder les
panneaux b à e dcf pourquoi pas dans
l'ordre alphabétique me direz vous vous
ne le saurez jamais
vous ne le saurez jamais et c'est
marrant parce qu'on en discute et du
coup avec des collègues et mes collègues
m'ont dit button je n'étais même pas
rendu compte que la figure à elle était
elle était complètement mélanger comme
ça et on a fini par conclure que mes
weeps c'est normal que tu te sois pas
rendu compte que la figure a été tout
péter ce parce que la figura ne sert à
rien les figures ne servent pas à
grand-chose globalement dans ce dans cet
article à part cette figure là la figure
3 qui montre les incisives donc il ya
deux petites incisive dans certains des
des squelettes de tyrannosaure alors que
d'autres squelettes de tyrannosaure ont
une seule petite incisive et la deuxième
à 6 iv grosse du coup donc deux petites
incisive ou une seule petite incisive sa
scène illustre quasiment rien voulu dire
si vous arrivez à comprendre ce qui
illustre hélas bah tant mieux pour vous
et puis après le reste c'est des graphes
donc c'est un article de taxonomie fin
des graphes et des tableaux c'est un
article de taxonomie qui ne qui ne
montre aucun fossile ce qui a quand même
un peu dommage pour un article de
taxonomie pareil le moment où une liste
c'est pareil ce graphe là il n'y lustres
rien vous imaginez que c'est l'évolution
de tyrannosaurus au cours du temps pas
du tout ça c'est
des gorgones russes et ça c'est
albertosaurus donc tyrannosaurus il il
est là c'est ces deux là tyrannosaurus
l'un est amorphe et robuste et là est un
mort gracile si je ne m'abuse voilà donc
est pareil la différence entre robuste
et gracile sur ces reconstructions là
bas je vous invite à essayer de l'avoir
moi je la vois pas donc les graphes
voilà les figures savent pas grand-chose
n'illustre pas grand chose du moins la
partie systématique n'a aucun espace
donc là dans ce paragraphe dans ce
groupe paragraphe là il ya trois et
trois nouvelles espèces du coup de
tyrannosaure alors regina il commence la
voyez
tyrannosaurus imperator comment cela et
tirano horus rex comment cela est le et
tout ça et d'un bloc donc là il ya un
éditeur par contre qu'il a pas fait son
boulot donc voyez c'est ça que je veux
dire l'article il a il a passé longtemps
dans les tuyaux et pourtant donne encore
l'impression de ne pas avoir passé
suffisamment de temps dans les tuyaux
donc ça c'est le premier problème le
deuxième comme j'ai dit le deuxième gros
problème c'est qu'il ya deux morts fait
qu'ils concluent à trois espèces et là
où c'est intéressant au niveau des
résultats c'est que donc l'hypothèse de
l'observation de base s'est il y a deux
morph la gracile d'autres robuste et
donc du coup quand ils font un diagramme
quand il quantifie cette robustesse de
la robustesse des eaux et font un
diagramme de la robustesse il trouve que
la robustesse en fait à une distribution
qui est normal et cette distribution
normale ça veut dire une chose simple ça
veut dire que vous avez une courbe comme
ça en cloche avec la moyenne de
robustesse au milieu ce qui veut dire
qu'en fait la moyenne de robustesse est
la condition d'une robustesse moyenne
est la condition primordiale chez
tyrannosaurus ce qui est en gros veut
dire qu'il n'ya pas de différence réelle
entre robuste et gracile se sont pas
deux catégories séparées il ya un
véritable continuum entre les deux le
seul moyen d'interpréter ça correctement
c'est de dire y'a qu'une espèce et à
côté de ça ils nous disent ben oui mais
non c'est pas qu'une seule espèce parce
que quand on met quand on compare la
robustesse de tyrannosaurus et c'est le
graphe que je vais vous montrer voilà
quand on compare la robustesse total de
tyrannosaurus la dispersion autour de la
droite de régression ici elle est
gigantesque plus grande que celle quand
on unit tous les tyrannosaures ou que
vous avez la droite de régression
effectivement la dispersion autour de la
droite de régression est plus faible
chez tous les autres tyrannosaure que
chez tyrannosaurus donc ça veut dire que
là sachant qu'il ya plusieurs genres de
tyrannosaure mais le binôme genre
espèces tyrannosaurus rex voilà on a
gorgo horus albertosaurus etc etc quand
on compare tyrannosaurus à tous ces
autres jambes en fait la variabilité de
robustesse entre tous les genres de
tyrannosaurus être moins grande que
celle à l'intérieur de tyrannosaurus rex
donc ils disent vous voyez bien que ça
fait plusieurs espèces et là la réponse
c'est ben non ça veut dire qu'il ya
plusieurs genres à l'intérieur de
tyrannosaurus déjà quantifier cette
variabilité c'est pas forcément très
pertinents mais quand bien même on la
considèrerait pertinente cette
variabilité de robustesse ben ça
voudrait dire qu'il y a plusieurs genres
à l'intérieur de tyrannosaurus or encore
une fois qu est-ce qui concluent ils
concluent pas qu'il ya trois genres de
tyrannosaurus il conclut qu il y a trois
espèces leur conclusion n'a aucun sens
c'est un peu dommage donc je pense pas
que cet article fera date je ne pense
pas que cette division de tyrannosaurus
en trois espèces fera date parce que
sept tirs cette division
n'a pas vraiment de sens en réalité par
rapport à leurs propres résultats je
veux dire c'est pas c'est pas que je
suis contre le fait de diviser
tyrannosaurus en trois espèces c'est pas
parce que tyrannosaurus c'est mon jouet
chéri favori c'est mon dinosaures
préféré nanana non ça n'a rien à voir
c'est vraiment il y à une observation de
base
2,2 morph des résultats sains qui a dit
qu'il ya une espèce 1 qui indique qu' à
plusieurs genres et une conclusion qui
n'a rien à voir ni avec cette
observation ni avec les observations de
base ni avec les résultats d'après ce
que j'ai pu voir sur les réseaux sociaux
les spécialistes des tyrannosaures ont
fait leur choix et à mon avis ne vont
pas suivre les conclusions de cet
article donc tyrannosaurus rex encore de
beaux jours devant lui
on continue avec une autre star du
crétacé le fameux spinosaurus
spinosaurus qui ô surprise encore
publiés dans la revue nature et ô
surprise on nous annonce qu'il est
aquatique dis donc on s'y attendait plus
un à force donc c'est toujours la même
équipe à nizar ibrahim et ses collègues
investie de la tâche de démontrer au
monde que spinosaurus était bel et bien
aquatique et cette fois ils ont regardé
la section des eaux donc des désolons
mais aussi des côtes et ce qu'ils ont
constaté bien c'est que les eaux étaient
était très épais chez spinosaurus donc
les eaux était ce qu'on appelle pâquis
ostéo sclérotique donc pas qu'ils
haussent terreau sclérotique ça veut ça
veut dire aussi dense et épais voilà
c'est ça que ça veut dire et c'est un
cas qu'on retrouve effectivement
essentiellement chez les espèces
aquatiques alors pas n'importe lesquels
espace aquatique les espèces qui sont
aquatiques mais pas pélagique donc ça
veut dire qu'ils vivent dans l'eau mais
pas en haute mer parce que en haute mer
on a les cétacés par exemple qui vivent
en haute mer et eux leur zone en tout
cas la plupart de leurs côtes de leur
zoo c'est à dire leurs côtes et leur
rôle on met les os du bras ne sont pas
pas qu'ils haussent totti qu'il ya que
les eaux de l'oreille chez les cétacés
qui sont réellement et un petit peu le
museau qui sont pas qu'ils ostéo
sclérotique chez les cétacés mais les
eaux des membres et des côtes ne sont
pas pas qu'ils aient ostéo sclérotique
qui sont au contraire très spongieuse
donc c'est vraiment les espèces qui
vivent dans un environnement d'eau peu
profonde qui ont les aux pâquis ostéo
sclérotique et ça c'est donc et ça c'est
ce qu'on trouve donc chez spinosaurus
ce qui démontrerait donc plus
spinosaurus est définitivement aquatique
ceci étant dit j'ai un peu de mal à
comprendre pourquoi ça ça finit publiée
dans nature parce que c'est déjà ce
qu'il disait en 2014 nizar ibrahim en
2014 dans la liste des arguments qui
comptent pour dire que spinosaurus était
semi aquatique il y avait déjà les
sections osseuse des os longs et des
côtes qui figurait dans cette liste et
il disait déjà que ces eaux était épais
et danse donc oui c'est un peu curieux
du coup de voir sa publié dans une très
très grande revue alors que c'est
finalement pas si nouveau que ça les
seules choses nouvelles donc c'est
qu'ils ont aussi inclus baryonyx et
soukhoumi mus alors baryonyx à des zoos
qui sont pas aussi épais et dense que
que spinosaurus mais qu'ils le sont
quand même un peu ce qui veut dire qu'il
était un petit peu semi aquatique et
puis vous avez souqués mais soukhoumi
muschi lui par contrat les au plus tôt
fin voyez que comparé à tyrannosaurus
ici c'est pas si différent de ce qu'on
voit chez chez tyrannosaurus là on a un
autre dinosaure hanté tonitrue ce qui
est un sauropode voyez ce n'est pas si
différent que ça non plus donc à côté de
ça vous avez le cayman ici qui est donc
semi aquatique et qui lui a encore ne
voyait une bonne fenêtre là au milieu de
ces eaux là ça ce n'est même plus lâché
spinosaurus donc voilà là sur le graphe
ici qui est un graphe très intéressant
et qui à mon avis résume à peu près tout
donc sur ce grave vous avez en rouge
tout ce qui est terrestre vous avez en
bleu tout ce qui est aquatique alors ils
appellent ça les plongeurs
et donc dans ces animaux aquatiques en
fait plus vous vous déplacez dans cette
direction vers en haut à gauche plus
vous êtes fortement aquatique en gros
donc bas de plus vous vous éloignez des
terrestre en fait et plus vous êtes
aquatique donc là vous avez
l'hippopotame qui est pas très très
aquatique est en haut à gauche vous avez
les des cétacés comme maiacetus l'a donc
spinosaurus il est quand même assez
éloignée des terres est re ceci étant
dit la séparation n'est pas parfaite
puisque vous voyez quand même que tu
oses aux russes qui est quand même
fortement fortement aquatique se trouve
là mais encore une fois les petits aux
russes c'est un animal pélagiques et les
animaux pélagiques on les eaux plus
poreux voyez que laïque tueuse russe on
n'a plus le pattern qu'on retrouve chez
les cétacés avec des os pour eux qui
sont vraiment des années ce sont
vraiment des animaux qui vivent dans un
milieu pélagiques qui ont les eaux pour
eux alors chez les cétacés je sais pas à
quoi ça servait chez les ichtyosaures
mais chez les cétacés ça sert à stocker
la graisse en fait ils ont la graisse
sous cutanée
qu'ils ne peuvent pas utiliser comme
réserves d'énergie parce que ils ont en
ont besoin pour conserver la chaleur de
leur corps donc c'est la grèce qu'il
stocke à l'intérieur de leurs zones
qu'ils vont utiliser comme réserves
d'énergie quoi donc c'est pour ça que
les cétacés ont les eaux pour j'ose
imaginer que c'était la même chose pour
les ichthyosaures mais bon les
ichthyosaures étant
du côté reptiles de la force peut-être
que c'était quelque chose de différent
en tout cas là il n'y a pas trop de
doutes sur le fait que spinosaurus il
tombe du côté aquatique de la force
franchement voilà il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas trop de doute à avoir sur les
conclusions de cet article à mon sens et
ça se voit bien aussi sur les
comparaisons je veux dire il n'y a pas
on va pas que croire les chiffres quand
on nous les montre ça se voit assez bien
sûr les comparaisons donc si j'arrive à
trouver les spinosaures donc voilà
spinosaurus et baryonyx qui ont des os
quand même super et paie donc si on les
compare au dessus à des animaux
franchement aquatique donc voilà un
phoque par exemple rhodos et husky est
une baleine à quatre pattes comme
maiacetus mais qui était déjà très très
franchement aquatique 1,10 us qui est un
cétacé très très très basale qui était
encore assez terrestre vous voyez qu'il
a encore une petite fenêtre donc ça
cette épaisseur et cette densité du
cortex osseux est vraiment un très très
bon indicateur de du mode de vie et là
on a forcé là on a ici aux eaux russes
par exemple oulala c'est vraiment très
très spongieuse là on abat les
basilosaurus qui vivait donc on retrouve
essentiellement dans des environnements
peu profonds et vous voyez c'est
cohérent avec une épaisseur et une forte
densité du cortex osseux donc il ya un
très très fort signal là qui est
indéniable le fameux spinosaurus était
semi aquatique baryonyx était semi
aquatique voire très aquatique mais
d'environnement d'eau peu profonde
puisque c'est encore une fois c'est
cette épaisseur cesr de ballasts pour se
maintenir sur le fond de l'eau or quand
vous êtes pélagiques vous avez pu le
fond de l'eau il est à plusieurs
milliers de mètres savait plus vraiment
de 25 il va falloir développer d'autres
adaptations pour devenir pélagiques donc
spinosaurus ils étaient au moins aussi
aquatique je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure un qu'un phoque ou qu'une
baleine à quatre pattes quoi de l'éocène
baryonyx il l'était probablement un
petit peu moins un petit peu moins
aquatique et soukhoumi mus là où c'est
intéressant c'est que lui ne l'était
probablement pas du tout ou presque pas
du tout et donc ça montre une certaine
diversité au sein de ces spinosaures
tous les spinosaures n'était pas
forcément
très très très aquatique spinosaurus
était un extrême et souquer mais mus
soukhoumi mu pardon était un autre
extrême on continue avec de la
paléobiologie de dinosaures mais cette
fois on retourne sur terre avec les
sauropodes et cette étude donc paru dans
current biology un autre grand journal
qui reconstitue en fait la démarche des
sauropodes alors là sur la figure ça se
sont pas très bien donc je vais vous
mettre une petite vidéo là maintenant
tout de suite donc sur cette petite
vidéo en fait vous allez voir que il
reconstitue la démarche des sauropodes
donc basé sur des empreintes de pas
voilà ils ont étudié tout une piste
d'empreintes de sauropodes pour arriver
à déterminer quelle était la démarche
des sauropodes enfin du sauropode qui a
fait cette piste donc qui est attribué à
un truc qui étaient proches des bras qui
autorise des et en ce qu'il reconstitue
en fait c'est que le ce sauropodes
marchait en vient enfin avec les avec un
pattern diagonale on va dire donc la
jambe la jambe et le bras opposés l'un à
l'autre en diagonale
bougeait à peu près en même temps et
donc ça fait un peu ça ressemble un
petit peu au trot des chevaux en fait
pendant le trot un cheval va faire la
même chose à savoir bouger
le bras droit la jambe gauche puis le
bras gauche avec la jambe droite puis le
bras droit avec la jambe gauche puis le
bras gauche avec la jambe droite donc
avec un pattern alternée en fait
diagonale donc apparemment c'est comme
ça que se déplaçait le sauropodes qui a
fait cette trace et ça c'est intéressant
parce qu'en fait c'est pas vraiment ce
qu'on voit chez les animaux de grande
taille aujourd'hui les mammifères de
grande taille comme l'éléphant par
exemple ils vont avoir plutôt tendance
et on pensait que les sauropodes se
déplacer comme ça ils vont avoir plutôt
tendance à avoir une démarche tripode
c'est à dire qu'il vaut mieux bouger
qu'un seul membre à la fois donc le bras
avant
donc le bras droit avant la jambe gauche
arrière le bras gauche avant la jambe
droite arrière est en fait ils vont
toujours avoir trois pieds sur enfin
c'est pas tout le temps évidemment il ya
des variations un chalet d'éléphants
sais pas c'est pas une loi absolue mais
les éléphants il aime bien faire ça ce
qu'ils ont au moins tout le temps trois
pattes sur le sol et quand on pèse très
lourd avoir le maximum de soutien au sol
c'est quand même intéressant et donc on
pensait que les sauropodes faisait
quelque chose comme ça on prend il y en
a qui avait proposé aussi que les
sauropodes pouvait marcher l'embl donc
l'angle c'est quand on bouge les deux
pattes du même côté vers l'avant c'est
ce que font par exemple les girafes les
girafes elle marche l'embl en avançant
ma main gauche pied gauche et puis main
droite pied droit puis main gauche pied
gauche puis main droit de pied droit
donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelle l'angle
et les éléphants quand il court enfin
quand il ne court pas les éléphants il
marche vite des éléphants ne court pas
de galope pas techniquement mais les
éléphants donc quand ils vont vite fonds
pratique l'angle aussi mais par contre
l'idée de voir déjà des sauropodes
marché autrement qu'en position tripode
c'est déjà assez provocant parce que oui
on s'imagine pas un machin qui est je ne
sais combien de fois plus gros qu'un
éléphant imaginer autrement qu'en et
gardant le maximum de surface au sol
donc on s'imaginait bien quand même
c'est ce repas de bouger qui ne seul
qu'une seule patte à la fois si vous
regardez par exemple je crois que c'est
sur la terre des dinosaures l'épisode
qui est consacré donc au sauropodes vous
les voyez bien marcher comme ça c'est à
dire il marche très lentement en
bougeant une seule patte à la fois donc
vous pouvez retourner voir sur la terre
des dinosaures je crois que c'est là
dedans que c'est très très bien illustré
et du coup bas apparemment ce n'était
pas le cas apparemment en tout cas pour
le spécimen qui a fait cette piste là ce
n'était pas le cas lui il marchait avec
les pieds en diagonale donc ils se
retrouvaient un moment où il n'avait
plus que deux pattes au sol c'est ça
l'idée et en bougeant les jambes les
bras en diagonale comme ça tac les tac
au tac eh ben il avait un moment du
mouvement il n'avait plus que deux
pattes au sol alors c'est les pattes
diagonale encore une fois donc ça veut
dire que le soutien au sol était était
quand même assez solide mais
la vache la pression que les gens
devaient prendre si c'était vrai si
c'est effectivement le cas la pression
que les jambes et les bras devait
prendre dans la tronche
pendant ces pendant cette phase où il
restait plus que deux pattes au sol ça
devait être assez ouf donc
voilà c'est provocateur provocateur est
provocatrice cette idée on reste avec
les dinosaures mais cette fois on se
déplace en france cocorico avec un
nouveau dinosaure qui a été décrit alors
surtout par des chercheurs basés en
espagne apparemment mais nouveau
dinosaure alors qui est pas vraiment une
nouvelle espèce puisqu'ils n'ont pas
réussi à l'identifier mais qui est basé
quand même sur un un joli fossiles qui
est cette griffe cette belle griffe en
forme de faucille qui doit vous rappeler
nos amis les raptor alors cette griffe
elle vient de fox amphoux dans le var et
fox amphoux c'est un site qui est très
connue puisque puisque il a donné
notamment le drôme et aux au rider varie
raptor le raptor du var comme son nom
l'indiqué varie raptor vient de fox
amphoux est donc maintenant il ya une
nouvelle griffe qui semble appartenir à
la drôme et aux ors et qui vient du même
site et ça c'est très très très
intéressant ils ont fait une analyse de
cette griffe alors la griffe elle est
stockée au musée d'espéraza qui est
alors qui est pas vraiment dans le var
du tout si on regarde la carte le musée
espère hazza voilà il est situé du côté
de perpignan là par la
met donc bon c'est un détail j'ai envie
de dire la chose importante c'est que
ils ont comparé du coup cette griffe à
celle de pyro raptor alors varie raptor
on connaît pas la griffe par contre pire
aux raptor on connaît la les griffes la
griffe en forme de faucille de pyro
raptor est donc en comparant ce cette
griffe mdee des 25 donc musée d'espéraza
musée des dinosaures d'espéraza des 25 à
celle de pyro raptor donc les deux
griffes en forme de faucille de pyro
raptor et à celle d'autres raptor qui
ont été découverts en europe et ailleurs
dans le monde eh bien il en conclut
qu'il ya quand même une certaine
ressemblance
entre ce nouveau drôme est aux ordres de
fox amphoux
et le pire aux raptor le fameux piron
raptor qui va d'ailleurs figurer dans la
saga jurassic world maintenant donc ça
c'est quand même super intéressant parce
que ça alors ils disent ce nouveau
spécimen nommé ne permet pas de soutenir
ou de réfuter la synonymie entre pire
aux raptor est vague et varient raptor
dont je rappelle que on a deux gros mais
aux orres en france mais certains
chercheurs ont proposé qu'en fait ce
n'était qu'une seule et même espèce mais
en tout cas moi ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est que sur le site ou
varie raptor a été découvert on trouve
une griffe qui ressemble beaucoup à
celle de pyro raptor
et ça enfin je veux dire ils ont beau
dire que ça n'a aucun rapport avec avec
la question de la synonymie entre pire
aux raptor et malgré varie raptor bas
quand même un petit peu si on trouve une
griffe qui ressemble à pire aux raptor
dans le site de var irap tort comme un
aveu
donc c'est intéressant c'est intéressant
ça rajoute une petite pierre à l'édifice
ça enrichit le registre fossile des
dinosaures théropodes en france registre
fossile d'ailleurs qui s'est trouvé très
très très enrichi avec ce nouvel article
dans deux géodiversité as la revue du
muséum d'histoire naturelle de paris
par un étudiant qui s'appelle evariste
mon voisin sous la supervision de ronan
allain de eric buffetaut et de laurent
picot donc là ses cocoricos à 200% ils
ont étudié les théropodes des vaches
noires et ils ont découvert donc qu'il y
avait toute une variété de mégalo zorro
idée d'allosaures et et un autre
spécimen apparemment de streptocoques on
dit luce aldo altdorf n6 donc voila c d
et puis il ya un résumé en français au
moins ça permet de comprendre si vous
n'êtes pas anglophone je ne peux pas ne
pas évoquer le fait que plusieurs des
spécimens qui ont été étudiés ici sont
dans des collections privées donc là le
matériel bon après c'est un matériel qui
est papa magnifique enfin c'est un peu
comme le drôme et aux orres juste avant
ça reste assez parcellaires mais vous
voyez il ya des jolies d'en préserver il
ya des jolies bout de fémur des belles
vertèbres plus ou moins jolie on est
bien d'accord mais voilà ça regardez
c'est pas mal ça c'est un petit max
hilaire et une petites mandibules là qui
appartenait peut-être ou peut-être pas
aux mêmes crânes j'imagine que la is si
le reconstitue sur le même crâne c'est
qu'il a de bonnes raisons de croire que
ça vient du même crâne dont il ya quand
même des jolies choses dans ce matériel
mais bon ça reste quand même du truc
très parcellaires très ont fait un peu
ce qu'on peut avec ce qu'on à quoi donc
mais bref oui je ne peux pas donc ne pas
évoquer le fait que la plupart de ces
fossiles ou beaucoup de ces fossiles
viennent en fait de collectionneurs
privés et que du coup encore une fois
c'est enfin moi je me sens en lisant ça
je
m'imagine un peu ces paléontologues qui
qui sont un peu sentis pris en otage
entre entre le fait que bas d'un côté
faut quand même les publier ces fossiles
et en plus on a la chance que le que le
collectionneur ouvre ses collections
donc je veux dire on va pas ne pas
sauter sur l'occasion de publier ce
matériel parce que je veux dire c'est
des dinosaures en france quoi on en a
pas tant que ça donc il faut quand même
les publier quoi c'est des théropodes en
plus c'est des grands carnivores les
mégalos zorro id les halles aux oraux
idc c'est quand même des trucs
impressionnants donc il faut il faut
saisir cette opportunité mais d'un autre
côté vous êtes obligé de faire un truc
qui est limite pas éthique du tout
je l'aimais pas limite pas éthique du
tout c'est un peu oxymore unique mais le
voila tu vous êtes obligé de faire un
truc qui n'est pas éthique qui va être
d'étudier du matériel qui va rester dans
des collections privées et du coup tant
que c'est dans des collections privées
basse et ça ça risque d'être perdue ça
risque d'être vendus ça risque de plein
de risques en fait que ce soit perdue
pour la science je ne peux que être
compatissant de bas de mes collègues du
muséum d'histoire naturelle de paris qui
ce qu'ils ont dû se sentir un peu qui
ont dû avoir ce sentiment d'être pris un
peu en otage par les collectionneurs
genre oui vous pouvez l'étudier mais non
sarah chez moi et à mon avis ce matériel
aurait dû finir dans les collections du
musée et non les collections des musées
sont pas juste des endroits où ils vont
prendre la poussière les fossiles vivent
dans les musées c'est dans les
collections qu'il meurt c'est dans les
collections qu'il meure d'une quasiment
littéralement parce que bangkok le
collectionneur meurent généralement les
fossiles sont vendus aux enchères sont
données sont perdues jetée à la benne ce
que vous voulez parce qu'on perd
l'information que le collectionneur
avait dans la tête aussi quand le
collectionneur meurt donc ça s'est
littéralement l'écho les fossiles en
collections privées moeurs et ensuite le
problème des collections privées c'est
que oui il faut vraiment faut vraiment
connaître qui est le collectionneur
avoir sa confiance pour qui vous ouvre
ses vitrines faut avoir cette personne
là dans vos dans vos contacts quoi alors
que les collections publiques ben voila
vous gueulez vous le trouvez et sait
faire en deux secondes faut sauter cette
image de la tête du musée qui l'est ce
qui laisse les choses s'empoussiérer
danser dans ses collections c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche sans transition
on va passer aux primates bah oui on va
pas faire un palais venus sans parler un
peu de sage donc aujourd'hui niveau
primates qu'est ce qu'on a déjà on a
sept cette étude parue dans la revue
respectable plos one
qui utilisent des techniques de
reconstruction faciale de type un peu un
peu le même type que ce qu'ils utilisent
en police scientifique pour reconstituer
les la face à partir des crânes qu'il
retrouve donc c'est eux c'est basé sur
des mesures et c est donc en utilisant
ces techniques et en les appliquant à la
fois humain et aussi aux singes moderne
et bien il trouve une très forte
corrélation justement entre l'os et la
viande de la face et cette forte
corrélation entre la position des eaux
et de l'or et puis la viande qu'on
trouve sur la face valeur permet de
reconstituer justement la forme du nez
et des lèvres chez lâcher les primates
modernes donc les grands singes moderne
et donc en partant du principe que cela
fonctionne bien les espèces modernes il
applique ça aux fossiles et donc ça nous
donne ceci donc ici on a les
australopithèques avec la
australopithecus africanus avec son nez
très très proche de celui d'un singe
australopithecus sediba dont on voit ici
le museau très court donc qui fait
penser pour plusieurs gens que
australopithecus sediba serait en fait
un représentant du genre homo on a ici
les parents trope donc robustus et
boisés et puis là on a les représentants
du genre homo avec les plus anciens
représentants du genre homo homo habilis
ici avec voyez le nez dont le il
reconstitue en fait la présence d'un
cartilage qui commence à faire
ressembler le nez à 1 et d'humains
moderne homo ergaster donc l'homo
erectus africains là qui commence
vraiment à avoir un nez fortement
humains ici au monal est dit là vous
avez qu à bout et donc aux mots
rhodésienne 6 ou au mode horde et
dahlberg m6 en fonction ou au mob oddo
and cie selon la terminologie que vous
voulez employés mais en tout cas voilà
le prix humain le plus proche d'homo
sapiens qu'on puisse l'être ou là on a
vraiment un et qui commence à avoir une
belle arcade saillantes comme chez homo
sapiens et là vous avez néandertal qu'il
a pour le coup avait vraiment un est
fortement développée avec cette grosse
arcade ici nasal qui donne un peu ce
n'est très fortement à qu'il a donc là
c'est une belle étude quand même qui
permet de reconstituer la phase deux de
nos ancêtres avec une précision quand
même qualité graphique je trouve assez
assez ou fait donc on voit bien la
transition en fait d'une aidé singes
verts le nez humain qui a eu lieu chez
les premiers représentants du genre homo
on reste chez les grands singes mais
cette fois les grands singes fossile
donc on n'est pas exactement dans la
lignée humaine on est un petit peu avant
la lignée humaine chez les grands singes
et cette étude donc qui nous propose une
grande revue phylogénétique en fait de
tous les grands singes connu fossile
donc c'est paru dans journal of human
evolution encore un journal très très
respectable et il ya plein d' analyse
phylogénétique qui ont été réalisés dans
tous les sens avec tous plein de
combinaisons possibles alors c'est très
bien résumé dans une figure final voilà
que je vous présente ici alors je sais
que suis le premier à gueuler à chaque
fois des cas une phylogénie de dessinés
à la main mais ça ça c'est la figure
synthétique de toutes les autres
phylogénie qui ont été faites au dessus
vous voyez qu'il y en a eu plein donc
ils ont essayé de faire une figure qui
synthétise un peu toutes les hypothèses
ensemble donc même si c'est destiné à la
masse ça quand même ça représente
quelque chose et donc cette figure
synthétique qui résume un peu tout les
analyse phylogénétique qu'ils ont fait
juste avant on peut voir qu'il ya encore
plein de points d'interrogation bien
évidemment à tous les résultats
phylogénétique non pas qu aux cordées
vers une seule vers un seul résultat
cohérent mais en commençant par les
homininés donc on voit les homininés
home australopithecus ici
penser gorilla qui sont leur groupe
frère donc le chimpanzés les gorilles
sont leur groupe frère là et donc ça ça
veut dire que cela voilà vous avez le
gorille qui est africain le chimpanzé
qui est africain australopithèques us et
aux maux qui sont africains donc là on a
vraiment un clad ici qui est 100%
africain
et là où ça devient intéressant c'est
que là on a des européens ici ou rano
pitt et cus et gréco pittacus je sais
pas si vous vous rappelez gréco pittacus
c'est celui qui a été découvert il ya
pas si longtemps que ça et puis qui sait
juste une mâchoire pas très très jolie
d'ailleurs et puis il ya une prémolaires
qui vient de bulgarie la mâchoire pas
très jolie qui vient de grèce qui donne
son nom gréco pittacus hélas prémolaires
qui vient de bulgarie je crois et qui
avait été proposé comme étant the
ancêtres des êtres humains et du coup ça
voulait dire que the humains ils étaient
d'origine européenne bon bah non on a là
vous voyez les êtres humains ils sont là
et gréco pittacus il est loin il est
loin et il forma clad avait cours à
noter qu'us donc ce qui n'est pas une
énorme surprise puisque brad pitt et cus
ça fait longtemps qu'on pense qu'il est
relativement proche donc des chimpanzés
les gorilles et des humains et on sait
qu'ils les européens donc là on agrico
pittacus qui finit au côté des hourras
no pity cus
d'ailleurs gréco pittacus a été pendant
un temps synonyme burano pitt et que
donc c'est vous dire si on s'attendait à
ce qu'ils soient proches
donc tout ça pour dire que là on a un
club européen donc le clad européen
groupe frère d'un clad africain et au
milieu de ça on an'a qualité qu ce qui
est un représentant africain des grands
singes et donc qui selon les analyses va
se brancher avec le clad européen ou
avec le clad africain donc en général et
bah ça donne un arbre qui est quand même
assez cohérent géographiquement et et
puis et puis qui teste enfin l'
hypothèse phylogénétique degré copie
accuse parce que je le rappelle moi
depuis le début je n'arrête pas de dire
ils ont balancé l'idée que grecque au
pit et cus était un grand singe
apparenté au mot en europe sans jamais
réaliser d'analystes phylogénétique et
comme je n'arrête pas de le dire bah a
déclaré ça c'est comme donner les
résultats d'une équation sans jamais
faire les calculs c'est ça n'a aucun
sens ça n'avait pas de sens c'était
c'était une opinion balancer comme ça
bon ben maintenant l'opinion a subi le
test les analyse phylogénétique
soutiennent que gréco pitt et cuche n'a
rien à voir avec homo australopithèques
le chimpanzé gorille est le chimpanzés
les gorilles et les humains ont tout à
voir les uns avec les autres dans ce
grand clac qui est définitivement
d'origine africaine donc la seule
question c'est est ce qu'on est en
afrique ici en fait par rapport à la
question de nacala pitt et macally
pittacus la seule question est de savoir
est-ce que l'ancêtre en commun de greco
pitt et cus du gorille des grands du
gorille du chimpanzé et des humains
est-ce que cet ancêtre la est d'origine
africaine ou pas l'idée d'une origine
des grands singes en nazis elle n'est
pas complètement stupide voilà mais par
contre les hominidés à savoir gorilla
pan et les homininés là par contre c'est
s'est définitivement africains et on va
parler un peu plus maintenant da
vertébrés nos amis les invertébrés a
qu'à chaque fois je néglige un petit peu
pendant mais pas les odieuses mais on a
eu des bonnes nouvelles au niveau des
invertébrés d'abord un article de nature
communications donc gros articles sur un
nouveau mollusques un mollusques
céphalopodes qui nous vient du
carbonifère de du montana et ce
mollusque que ce n'est pas n'importe
quel mollusques puisqu'il s'agit d'un
très très beau très beau fossiles vous
voyez de poulpe a préservé voyez tout le
tissu mou magnifiquement préservé ici
donc là vous avez le manteau et là vous
avez les tentacules et les bras est donc
ce qu'il ya d'intéressant avec cet
animal c'est que le corps est tout mou
ce qui indique que ce qui indique qu'il
a une forte affinité avec nos pieuvre et
de poulpe actuelle par contre ici vous
voyez les bras 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 huit bras
en tout et vous avez deux longs
tentacules donc en tout il y a dix 10
appendice sur cet animal donc vous avez
le corps mou des des pieuvres enfin des
poulpes avec les d'ibra
des calmars et donc ce qui est
intéressant avec ça c'est que on a dans
cette file au génie des céphalopodes
c'est très très très bien résumé on a là
les nautiles aux ide donc les nautiles
et c'est qui ce qui diverge des la base
de l'arbre dès l'origine des
céphalopodes au cambrien et donc ils ont
des coquilles et donc là vous avez la
coquille qu'on appelle le fragment
caunes qui est conservée ici chez les ch
et les ancêtres de ce qui va être
l'ancêtre en commun des calamars et des
pieuvres que vous voyez là donc là vous
avez la pieuvre classique j'ai envie de
dire là vous avez la pieuvre dame ball à
celles qui ont les les oreilles sur le
côté et là vous avez les vampires aux
les vampires au mof qui sont ces espèces
de pieuvre un peu bizarre qui vivent
dans les hauts fonds qui sont toutes
rouges qui ont des pointes à la place
des ventouses et qui ont une espèce de
membranes qui relie les les bras entre m
donc les bras sont reliés par cette
espèce de
deux membranes qui donne cet aspect de
cap et comme ils sont tous rouge ça fait
penser à dracula et en plus il ya ces
pointes hyper gothique à la place des
tentacules qui donne un aspect très
voilà tu es trés trés vampire ya un
trait dracula cette année mal d'où son
petit nom
est donc ces animaux-là eu non plus de
co qui sait ce qui est représentée ici
en bleu la plus du tout de coquilles
chez ces animaux là mais à la base tout
le monde avait une coquille les nautiles
aux ide et les ancêtres des pierres et
des calmars
la coquille a été conservée chez les
bébés les mno ide dont celle et bellême
need donc le fragment connaît c'est ce
qu'on appelle le frag locaux qui étaient
en plus chez les b les minots id
supplémenté par un rostre donc un rostre
qui venait en plus par dessus le
fragment caunes donc ça c'est ce qu'on
connaît chez les b les mini télé belem
need sont de proches parents des
calamars que vous voyez là qu'on appelle
les dca branche ils ont dix appendice
huit bras et deux tentacules de longs
tentacules
donc mais par contre les calamars ils
ont perdu leur coquille et kalmar ils
ont un petit résidus de fragments caunes
qui s'appelle la plume vous avez
certainement entendu parler de ça donc
et puis vous avez leurs cousins les
sèche qui évidemment on l'os de seiche
qui ressemble beaucoup d'ailleurs c'est
une version plus grosse des de la plume
des calmars mais c'est un c'est un
événement convergent avec les pieuvres
et les poulpes parce que justement ils
sont proches parents des baies les
mythes qui eux conservé une coquille
donc un côté de ça on a sept autres que
clad qui a divergé décalage des calamars
et des baies les unités qui a donné donc
naissance à nos pieuvre hainaut poulpe
est donc tout à la base de cet arbre on
avait autrefois idaho téthys donc qu'il
n'est aussi d'amérique du nord comme son
nom l'indiqué qui datait du trias ce
nouveau fossile là et bien il pousse
l'origine de tout ce beau monde
jusqu'aux carbonifère donc là on était
au trias on a sauté le permis a un
intérêt direct au carbonifère juste pour
vous montrer notre protège octopus
national à celui qui vient d'ardèche et
qui est très très bien préservé la le
jolis petits poulpes bien préservés
d'ardèche de là vous de ce
la voulte sur rhône il est là donc c'est
déjà un proche parent des vampires aux
morts feu donc la cie l'ipsi mopo dit il
indique qu'il a déjà plus rien voilà il
ya plus de frags moko n'ya déjà plus
rien il ya même pas de plumes et c'était
déjà le cas au carbonifère donc ça ça
indique quand même une origine très très
très profonde et ça repousse l'origine
des des ancêtres des poulpes et des
pieuvres très très loin dans le passé
très très loin dans le palais aux os x
alors que jusque-là on restait dans le
mésozoïque avec ida autodis donc c'est
quand même un progrès non négligeable et
le deuxième truc à propos de 6 lip6 mopo
dit pas c'est que contrairement aux
octopode il a dit ibra file à huit bras
et de tentacules donc ce qui est un
caractère qui montrent en fait que la
condition qu'on voit chez les calmars
actuel est en fait une condition
ancestrales pour tous les pour
probablement pour tous les colloïdes
donc pour tout ce qui est de ces
céphalopodes sans coquille enfin un frag
mokono relativement réduit donc c'est
quand même une découverte super
intéressante et qui repousse l'origine
comme ils le disent ça repousse
l'origine de tout ce beau monde d'à peu
près 80 millions d'années
180,2 millions d'années d'ailleurs si on
arrondit correctement c'est quand même
un bon dans le temps ça vous comble on
va dire une lignée fantôme de façon
assez magistrale on continue avec les
invertébrés et maintenant on parle de
petits de petits bivalves qui ont été
retrouvés à l'intérieur de la vénus de
willendorf donc la vénus de willendorf
c'est cette vénus l'a donc cette vénus
là elle a trente mille ans mais par
contre elle a été taillée dans une roche
qui l avait des millions d'années
évidemment les fossiles qui à
l'intérieur de la vénus ces petits
bivalves dont je vais vous parler qui
ont été retrouvés à l'intérieur de la
vénus ne ne sont pas des bivalves qui
qui date de la même époque que la vénus
ils sont évidemment beaucoup plus
violent venus elles mêmes environ trente
mille ans les bivalves qui sont à
l'intérieur vous voyez donc vous pouvez
voir ici ils ont été retrouvés grâce à
un scanner donc on les a passées aux
rayons x et grâce à ça on a retrouvé
plein de petits fragments de bivalves
dont celui là qui est très très très
très joli et identifiable puisqu'on a
encore sa son articulation donc il
appartient à la famille des oxydes
comité est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
donc ces cas grâce à ces bivalves ils
ont et à d'autres éléments comme les aux
élites alors les aux élites ce sont des
débiles
c'est déboule dans la roche on les voit
elles sont partout le dire tous les
petits points là ce sont des zoos lite
on les voit aussi la tous ces petites
boules que vous voyez là ça ça s'appelle
des élites ont des audits voilà pour ne
pas faire la liaison que ça s'appelle
pas des zones dites ça s'appelle days
aux élites voilà donc ces seize olite
sont des petites boules qu'on retrouve
dans la roche alors elles peuvent être
d'original guerre elles peuvent être
d'origine de plein d'autres origines
différentes c'est même pas forcé d'être
des fossiles en fait c'est aux élites
mais leur distribution leur taille etc
montrent qu'en fait la vénus donc là
vous voyez ça un diagramme de la
distribution en fait de la taille et de
la taille et de
patterns de distribution de la densité
de distribution de ces all it dans la
roche
permet en fait de placer la venus ici en
verre
sur ce diagramme donc c'est un aspect
assez classique et en fait sa place
notre venus à côté ici d'un site qui
s'appelle la sega diyala donc c'est au
lit tu nous indiques en fait que la
vénus a été probablement fabriqué à
partir d'une roche qui provenaient
d'italie donc la vénus de willendorf ici
c'est là que c'est de là que vient
vidanov a probablement été fabriqués à
partir de roches des alpes des alpes
italiennes donc de la sega diyala ici et
ça c'est cohérent avec les fossiles
qu'on retrouve à l'intérieur puisque je
sais auxi tome idées on les retrouve
aussi dans ces mêmes roche donc ça c'est
quand même très très très intéressant ça
montre justement comment la géologie et
la paléontologie peuvent interagir avec
l'archéologie pour permettre de retracer
bas des voies commerciales c'est
exactement ce qu'ils ont tracé la voie
là les deux les deux voies commerciales
possible qui ont permis en fait d'amener
la roche delà de la vénus depuis son
point d'origine jusqu'au point la
découverte dans le registre
archéologique à villaines dorff donc ça
c'est quand même une belle un bel
exemple de sciences collaborative un bel
exemple j'ai envie de dire de
multidisciplinarité donc la géologie qui
travaille avec la paléontologie qui
travaille avec l'archéologie pour nous
offrir une belle histoire publiée dans
scientific report donc publié quand même
à juste titre dans une revue
prestigieuse et on va terminer sur une
note de légèreté avec le musée
d'histoire naturelle de tokyo qui nous
propose une exposition pokémon fossiles
c'est quand même super cool alors
évidemment il ya plein de vidéos qui ont
été faites sur les fossiles enfin les
pokémon qui ont été inspirés par des
vrais faux cils le musée de tokyo
transformer ça en réalité en
reconstituant bien les fossiles des
enfin en reconstituant les squelettes de
ces pokémon fossile donc je connais pas
les noms pour être tout à fait honnête
je me suis arrêté à la première
génération je suis je suis moi-même à
dinosaures du gaming mais bon enfin je
veux dire c'est assez évident voilà le
rapport qu'il ya entre certains de ces
pokémon donc voilà là il s'appelle
tyrant romans en anglais je suis pas sûr
du nord en français mais ils ont quand
même fait une belle exposition en
mettant à chaque fois en parallèle du
coup le pokémon alors là par exemple ce
pokémon avec son équivalent fossiles le
tricératops ici donc si vous voulez il
ya cette page là qui est en français
j'ai réussi a quand même trouvé une page
qui en parlait en français donc je vous
mettrai le lien dans la description pour
que vous puissiez aller lire et si ça
vous intéresse et que vous avez un
billet d'avion à perdre ben vous pourrez
aller visiter ça
voilà c'était paléo news je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens et je vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]